so now we're going to talk about
something that is kind of a specific
part of Big Data so the velocity part
huge amounts of data being generated all
the time which essentially is a data
stream so that's a flow of instances so
you could have a flow of images coming
in have a flow video coming in or just a
flow of essentially lines to go into a
database the thing about the dynamic
data is that the patterns within it can
change so if we've got for example a
static machine learning model that's not
going to deal very well with a changing
pattern happening in the data we build a
single model at the start we use it to
make predictions on later data the model
accuracy can kind of degenerate over
time as that data changes the problem of
kind of designing algorithms to deal
with this real time data there's been a
research topic for kind of several years
now and there's several real world
applications on top of that as well
so if you think about banks trying to
detect fraud as patterns change of
different forwards occurring they want
their models to kind of be able to
update all the time similar for
intrusion detection systems and computer
networks they want to be able to update
and keep on top of what is happening
ideally you would want this to happen
automatically so minimum interference
from humans because otherwise they've
got to spot when changes are happening
we just want the machines to be able to
do it by themselves so if you think
about a traditional classification
problem on a static batch of data you
assume you have all of that data there
already you have your training test set
and you have instances with features
which X and then there's some unknown
function f of X which gives you the
class label and you want to find a
hypothesis that gives you the best
prediction possible so what kind of
approximates this function as well as
possible so you have a red class and a
green class and we have instances that
look like this our function f of X may
create a class boundary that looks like
this so anything on this side is red
anything on this side is green our model
doesn't know that but we use standard
machine learning techniques decision
trees new or networks whatever you want
and it learns a boundary that looks like
that and so that will do okay on
whatever dates that we have it's not
effect but it may get the results that
we want this is static classifications
we already have all our data so we've
got our data we've done our machine
learning this is the decision boundary
that we've learnt the dotted line is
what is actually the boundary
this gives okay results let's now say
that this is happening in a data stream
so we get this data originally and we
build this model but then later on we
have a similar distribution of instance
arriving however what now happens is
that some of these instances are now in
reality in a different class so the true
boundary is now here but we still have
our model with this decision boundary
and so we're now predicting instances
here and here into the wrong class if we
use that exact same model so what we
would see in this case in centage
accuracy over time you would see at this
change point accuracy would plummet
so this problem here is called real
concept drift what is effectively
happened here is that this function the
unknown function has changed but we've
kept our hypothesis our machine learning
model exactly the same and so it starts
to perform badly we can also have a
similar problem called virtual drift and
what would happen in this case is that
the target decision boundary has stayed
the same from this original but the
instances we now see in the stream are
somewhere else in the feature space
let's say we now see data like this so
though the kind of optimal decision
boundary is in exactly the same place we
now have different data that means that
are predicted boundary it's going to
give this instance as wrong because we
haven't got a way of incorporating
information from this instance into the
original model that we built both of
these will create this decrease in
accuracy so we can also look at the
drift in the data streams in terms of
the speed they happen so something that
would give us an accuracy plot that
looks like this is called sudden drift
we go from straight from one concept in
the data stream so one decision boundary
straight to another one another possible
thing that could happen
is that our accuracy looks like this so
rather than this sudden switch this
decision boundary gradually shifts save
me your life if we're looking at a very
very oversimplified intrusion detection
system we have only two features that
we're looking at in the original dataset
anything with these features this is a
security problem and intrusion anything
on this side is good in this case what
happens is that suddenly there's a new
way of attacking the network and so
suddenly what was here is now not good
so we see those patterns and we say ok
no that counts as an intrusion in this
case what it means is that we see
something that we've not seen before so
the model hasn't been trained with any
similar data and so it could get it
right it could fall somewhere up here
and we correctly say this is bad but it
could also fall in an area that we
didn't learn the decision boundary so
well so yeah we get that prediction
wrong we just looked at what the
problems are with using a single static
model when we're dealing with incoming
data over time the distribution changes
and we start to see a decrease in
accuracy on whatever model we built so
what happens in kind of a stream machine
learning algorithm would be so first of
all you've got X arriving this is your
instance in our previous example this
would just have two values associated
with it what would first happen is we
make a prediction so in the
classification example we classify this
yes it's an intrusion no it's not
intrusion using the current model that
we have then what happens is we update
whatever model we have using information
from X and we'll talk about some of the
ways that this is done in a second and
one of the kind of caveats with stream
machine learning is that you need for
this to happen you need to have the real
class label if you're doing
classification so in order to
incorporate information from this
instance into whatever model you've got
you need to have that label there now in
some cases it's very easy to say we've
seen this data this is what it's
classified us and we
do that immediately if we're thinking
about making weather predictions we can
almost immediately say yes this is what
the weather is like it may be a day's
delay but yeah we can
that's pretty immediate thing four
things for example for detection you may
see a pattern of data you may predict it
is not being fought and then suddenly
two days later this person figures out
that actually there's something wrong
with their bank accounts they phone up
and it does turn out to be fraud and so
we'd only have the label for that data
after that has happened
the final bit is to update the model at
this point and so the goal of updating
the model over time is so that rather
than having a performance plot that
looks like this
so we go from 95s and accuracy down to
20% accuracy we instead end up with
something that okay we may drift a
little bit here and have a tiny
performance decrease but the model
should very quickly recover back to the
original level and we still have a high
performance so that's the goal of this
model update there's various approaches
we can take so the first one is explicit
drift handling which means that we first
of all detect when a drift happens in
the data stream so to do that we have
drift detection methods and these are
usually statistical tests that look at
some aspects of the data arriving so if
the distribution of the data we see
arriving and the distribution of the
classes we see is changing if morph like
that as a drift some of these we'll also
look at the performance accuracy of the
classifier so if the classifier
performance suddenly drops we can say
well we've probably got a drift here we
need to do something to the model to
mitigate this who spots that though is
it you know is there an algorithm that
actually spots that something's
different to what it should be yes so
there are various statistical tests that
will do this that will kind of just
measure things like the mean of the data
arriving and be able to spot things that
have changed basically so yeah once we
detected that a drift has happened we
then want to take some action the first
thing that we could do is we could do a
complete replacement of the model so we
get rid of whatever model we had before
and we we have taken chunk of recent
data
and we retrain the model on that and
continue using that for predictions
until we've hit another drift this is
okay but it means that we could be
getting rid of some information in the
previous model that is maybe still going
to be useful in the future so then there
are also methods that we'll look at
specific parts of the model and say okay
this specific part of it is causing a
performance decrease so let's get rid of
this we can then learn from new
instances something to replace this that
will do it better basically so if you
think of a decision tree if you can
detect that there are certain branches
in that decision tree that are no longer
making good predictions you can get rid
of them and we grow the tree to perform
better prune it yeah exactly it is
called pruning you prune yeah you prune
the branches off the tree there are no
longer performing as you want them to
the alternative to explicit handling is
to do implicit drift handling so rather
than looking at the data or looking at
the performance and saying something has
changed we need to take action we're
just continually taking action there are
various approaches to implicit drift
handling so the first and probably most
simple one is to use a sliding window so
if we imagine we have the data stream
with instances arriving like this we
could say we have a sliding window of
three instances and we learn a model off
of them we then take the next three
learn a model off of them so as each
instance arrives we get rid of the
oldest instance and this makes the
assumption that the oldest instances are
the least relevant this is usually the
case it's kind of a valid assumption to
make
so this performs okay the problem with
this though is that it kind of provides
a crisp cut off points every instance
within this window is treated with
exactly the same kind of impacts on the
classifier they were weighted the same
so we can introduce instance weighting
so that older instances will have a
lower weight their impact on the
classifier will be less so again the
more recent instances will be have the
largest impact on the current model and
then again these algorithms that we'll
use instance weighting will usually have
some threshold so once the weight gets
below a certain point they say that's
the instance gone we delete it
presumably the windows can be larger or
smaller yes so setting the window size
is a pretty important parameter
if you have a window that is too large
then okay you're getting a lot of data
to construct your model from which is
good and cents between learning more
data usually good what it also means is
that if there's very short-term drifts
so this drift happens and then we don't
learn from that drift if that makes
sense because we see that all as one
chunk of the data again if you didn't
set the window to be too small we can
react very well to very short-term
drifts in the stream but you then have a
very limited amount of data to work on
to construct the model so there are
methods that will automatically adjust
the window size so during times of drift
the window size will get smaller so we
want to be very rapidly changing the
model and then during times when
everything is kind of very stable the
window will grow to be as large as
possible so that we can use as much data
to construct this model as possible so
the problem weird sliding windows and
instance weighting is that you need all
of those instances available to
construct the model continuously so
every time you add a new instance and
delete another one you need to
reconstruct that model and so the way we
can get around this is by using single
pass algorithms so we see each instance
once use it to update the model and then
get rid of that instance it's probably
still in long-term permanent storage but
in terms of what is being accessed to
construct this algorithm it's gone now
in that respect then you've got
information out of the instance but you
don't need the instance itself yeah
exactly so we see the instance we
incorporate what we can from it into the
current model we get rid of it and that
instances impact is still in the model
an example would be a decision tree so
decision trees are kind of constructed
by splitting nodes where we're going to
get a lot of information gained from
making a split on a certain attribute so
as the data stream changes the
information gained that we might get and
some of these nodes may change so if we
say get a new instance and it will say
okay now this actually makes this a
split worth making we can make that
split continue growing the tree and then
that instance can go we don't need it
anymore but we still have the
information from it in our model so
we've got our implicit and explicit
drift handling appro
you can also have hybrids approaches so
the explicit drift handling is very good
at spotting sudden drift so anytime
there's a sudden change there'll be a
sudden drop in performance that's very
easy to pick up on with a simple
statistical test but when we then add in
the implicit drift handling on top of
that it means that we can also deal very
well with gradual drift so gradual drift
is a bit more difficult to identify
simply because if you look at the
previous instance or like say that 10
previous instances with a gradual drift
you're not going to see a significant
change so it's a lot harder to detect by
combining the implicit and explicit
drift timing methods we end up with a
performance plot that would look
something like this we maintain pretty
good performance for the entire duration
of the data that's arriving the problems
of a changing data distribution and not
the only problems with streams and so if
you can imagine a very high volume
stream and high-speed got a lot of data
arriving in a very short amount of time
if you take a single instance of that
data stream and it takes you like five
seconds to process it but in that 5
seconds you've had 10 more instances
arrive you're going to get a battery of
instances very very quickly so you need
to be the model update stage needs to be
very quick to avoid getting any backlog
the second problem is that with these
algorithms we're not going to have the
entire history of the stream available
to create the current model so the
models need to be for example the single
path algorithms that can say we don't
need the historical data that we have
the information we need from it but we
don't need to access these because
otherwise you just end up with huge huge
data sets having to be used to create
these models all the time and again
these streams of potentially infinite we
don't know when they're going to end and
we don't know how much data they're
going to end up containing most of the
kind of
and well-known machine learning
algorithms have been adapted in various
ways to be suitable for streams so they
now include update mechanisms so they're
more dynamic methods so this includes
but decision trees neural networks k
nearest neighbors there's also
clustering algorithms have also been
adapted so basically any classic
algorithm you can think of there's
multiple streaming versions of it now
so if you are interested in these
streaming algorithms there's a few bits
of software that you could look at for
example there's the mower suite of
algorithms which interfaces with the
worker data mining tool kit this is free
to download and use and includes
implementations of a lot of popular
streaming algorithms it also includes
ways to synthesize data streams so
generate essentially a stream of data
that you can then run the algorithms on
and you can control the amount of drift
that you get how certain it is and
things like that
and that's quite good to play around
with to see the effects that different
kinds of drift can have on accuracy in
terms of big data streams specifically
there's software such as the spark
streaming module for Apache spark well
there's also the more recent Apache
flink that are designed to process very
high volume data streams very quickly
you just mentioned some yourself where
people can download and have a play with
but I mean in the real world as an
industry and websites and things that
services that we use every day he was
using these streaming algorithms and so
a lot of the big companies or most
companies to be honest will be
generating data constantly that they
want to model so for example Amazon
recommendations like what to watch next
what to buy next they want to understand
changing patterns so that they can keep
updating whatever model they have to get
the best recommendations again
optimizing ads to suggest based on
whatever searching history you have
that's another thing that is being done
via this so yeah there are a lot of
real-world applications for this stuff
now I've got the token so I can load a
value in add the value emerged or into
it and store it back and hand
and now I've got the token again I can
load something into its my register you
and do the computation split across
those machines so rather than having one
computer going through I don't know a
billion database records you can have
each computer going through